uh these are my institutional
affiliations you can contact me
at s dixon at wolfram.com or s dixon at
mum.edu i'm going to tell you on
semi autobiographical story about how i
helped danny hillis create the equation
of time cam for the clock of the long
now
in 1996 i was working on the dinosaur
production
about across the street from where danny
was a
uh disney corporate fellow at
imagineering
he was designing the clock around this
time just getting started he had seen my
illustrations in the second edition of
the mathematica book
and so he said that i was the only one
he could think of
who could make a machine part from a
mathematical equation
so the problem of keeping accurate time
for 10 000 years
one idea is a solar synchronizer the
problem is the solar synchronizer sees
sundial time which needs a calendrical
calculation to convert to
like atomic clock time so uh the
analemma
is the position of the sun in the sky
ever
at the same time of day for a year and
it's because the earth axis is tilted
and it gets even worse because
uh the equation of time morphs over
the period of 26 000 years the
with the precession of the equinoxes so
uh danny gave me a uh mathematica
notebook with the equation of time in it
oh yeah uh the right right hand uh
side of this slide is an analemma
sundial that that
has the conversion it's the offset
between
local solar time and absolute time
you can interact with the equation of
time cam
in the wolfram demonstrations project
and that really brings it uh
brings it home a lot better than than
just still pictures here
but here here are some still frames from
the the equation of time
demo you can see how the equation of
time morphs
over uh this is an expanse of 12 000
years that that's uh
cast onto the cam for the clock so how
do we turn this into a physical thing
in 19 you know 1996 we use stereo
lithography
or laminated object manufacturing
computer-aided manufacturing applied to
a mathematical equation so
this is this is the 1989 first
advertisement for mathematica
and it's uh executable code that looks
like
uh mathematics from an academic text and
here's uh
the um computer computer-aided
manufacturing part is
is making a displaced surface with an
edge on it that can enclose
material because uh mathematically
thin uh surfaces can't be physically
built
and so i came up with a data structure
to do this it associates
um faces with edges and edges with faces
uh so you can do the mesh displacement
you can get uh
consistent normals and do the mesh
displacement uh i
i wrote a paper in 1990 that was never
published but andrew glassner
published winged edge models in graphics
gyms 2
the next year so it got published
here is some mathematica code for the
iconic collab yell manifold and the
right-hand side of the slide is the
uh the traditional form of the same
thing as you would see a typeset in
mathml or something like that and so
here's the
uh the mathematical graphic of the
columbial manifold along with a
stereolithograph
of the columbial manifold
you know natural mathematics compiled
into
a 3d surface the equation of time
mathematics
you can download from the wolfram
demonstrations project
and it really doesn't look much better
in the calendrical calculations book
than it looks right here
and so uh what i did in 1996 was
uh some fairly fairly crude
computer-aided
uh manufacturing to turn it into an stl
file
and then danny did the casting
to turn it into a
machine part for the first prototype and
and it's uh
it's on display at the royal observatory
in greenwich england
so it's a an iconic object in its own
right
now and here's just another plug for my
employer
stephen wolfram is doing fundamental
physics again
and i think it's really cool and it's an
open project any anybody can
anybody can join and contribute to the
uh
to finding a fundamental theorem of
physics and computation
and thanks to the long dal foundation
and brady
for uh allowing me to be here
you